Garcia beat Justin Rose in the first
hole of a sudden-death playoff to win
the green jacket he had finished in the
top 10 at Augusta three times before now
here's the third Spaniard to win the
Masters Sergio we're thrilled to have
you here in congratulation again thank
you guys can you just tell us what it
felt like for you what you was going
through your mind when the ball went in
the cup well you could see it yes and
you can hear it my boy was insane I was
just screaming yeah just pretty much
screaming if I remember correctly I was
screaming yes in Spanish I was gonna see
and bamas and but it was just constant
screaming why'd it take you so long I
wish I could tell you but it's I think
life has a purpose for all of us and for
me was meant to be now and I'm glad it
was because because of what all the
things that happened throughout my
career I think I've learned so much and
I it helped me grow up not only as a
golfer as a person so and it probably
made this victory taste even even better
than yeah it was wonderful to see you
and Justin rose at the end and I know
that you were good friends and it was
just also a display of terrific
sportsmanship yes I think I mean my my
philosophy when it comes down to to
playing golf is I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try my hardest to to beat whoever is
next to me but but I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to do because because I play better
than them not because I'm tricking into
or trying to make them feel bad or
something to make them play worse so I
wanna I want to be Justin like like a
beating on Sunday you know making very
important ego and 15 and then very
didn't bring the extra hole I don't
wanna you know do any gamesmanship to to
make him feel uncomfortable because that
would make me feel uncomfortable and
then probably the way I am I wouldn't be
able to play the way I know how to play
because I will be feeling out of place
when you missed that putt on 18 that
sent you into into the into the playoff
what did you say to yourself well the
same thing I was saying I was telling
myself I mean I hit a good putt I I
didn't he missed his putt too yeah I
think we both hit good putts
we both misread them I hit that a very
similar pattern practice round and and
the both times it went a little left so
I didn't even ask my caddie for a read
or anything because I was confident I
knew I knew exactly what I wanted to do
with the pot I knew it was a quick putt
so I just needed to get it going I
thought okay you see right on the right
edge he's going to break a little left
and just just put a good stroke on it be
confident and I did and unfortunately
went straight so but I did what I wanted
to do so I was still feeling good about
it yeah I was playing well all day I was
I felt calm so I knew I was I could
probably have another chance and I just
need to to go out there and do it in the
playoff you did it you've gotten
congratulations all around the
congratulation tour continues you've
also gotten congratulations from Tiger
Woods with whom you've had a complicated
relationship what did that feel like
yeah it's great
I mean there's been so many different
congratulations from so many people and
friends friends of mine and fellow
players telling me that they were crying
watching it I mean it was amazing and
Danny Willett he was when we bought the
cabin he was crying hugging me and
everything so last year's champion yeah
but yeah it is great I think at the end
of the day we all we all people we will
do respect each other and you know we
all have a differences but you know we
have to be bigger bigger people and
bigger person and kind of put those
things aside one you can't hear from
because he passed away better too early
an age with Seve Ballesteros
unfortunately yeah I would have been it
would have been great I mean all of that
well I talked to him before the Spanish
team for and after yes but unfortunately
seve is not here anymore but it would be
nice to to see him that Sunday when when
it happened but I'm sure he was looking
at it from from out there from so I know
you're getting married
this year congratulation you and I and
so Charlie told me that your fiancee is
also a golfer yeah she and she's helped
you make a better be a better golfer god
yeah yeah she doesn't she doesn't
coached me no just wait till you get
married right now but she she played a
she play collegiate golf
uh yeah yeah University of Texas that's
awesome yeah so um yeah she's turned me
into a into a longhorn
Wow you know where the game jacket would
you get married I don't know we're
considering it women we've been talking
about it I'm seas she's up for it when
it gets closer we'll make a decision so
now that you've gotten past this you can
think about the Grand Slam can't you
yeah it would be great it would be great
I mean it you can't win them all if you
don't win the first one there you go
okay the winner gets to pick the menu
for the champions in air the next
masters thought about it yes I've
thought about if not this year I thought
about it before okay so for a long time
it's going to be a Spanish dish yeah
it's going to be one of my favorite
dishes in Spain but me I don't know if I
should be looking okay jeez as we say
right yeah it is a good tea soda but
it's gonna be it's gonna be delicious
oh well great well Sergio
congratulations and thank you for being
here with us thank you it's a pleasure
such a thrill to meet you and watch you
play golf so program thank you
thank you